a moment of history
and much needed hope for america
the first coveted vaccines now going
into the arms of frontline healthcare
workers
medics battling a fierce second wave
and now frustrating skepticism around a
vaccine
that could end the pandemic how does it
feel
it feels great i'm happy to be to serve
as a role model
to serve to say that this is safe that
is perfectly fine
it's based on science and then we
encourage
everyone when it becomes available to
take the vaccination
when the outbreak hit in the spring new
york was the epicenter
since then three hundred thousand
americans have lost their lives to
covid19
ten months on a complex vaccine rollout
is now in motion
state by state it's hoped a hundred
million americans will be inoculated by
the end of march
many hurdles lie ahead before that
this is an important moment in america's
history but the vaccine will be no quick
fix deaths have climbed to more than
three thousand
a day now due to coronavirus and one of
the government's leading advisers has
warned
we could see 9 11 style fatalities
every day for the next two to three
months
but it's a historic day in america for
two reasons
a vaccine delivered by the speed of
science
and a slow painful transition to a new
presidency
with the electoral college formally
voting for joe biden
this despite donald trump's ongoing
false claims
he won the election i am pleased to
announce that
joseph r biden has received 16 votes for
president of the united states
the vaccine came too late to save donald
trump's presidency
for many though it's state governors
who've rolled up their sleeves to tackle
the pandemic
and the health community is still
bracing for soaring cases around
christmas
sandra today represents immense hope
much needed hope
but how concerned are you about the
holiday season from what you're seeing
at the moment
so i'm concerned that people are going
to gather
so i'd say to people there is hope
let's put off the celebrations let's do
them virtually this year
so that we can all be together next year
the pandemic was politicized early on
here
and at least 75 of americans
need to be vaccinated before the country
can declare victory in this crisis sally
lockwood sky news new york